the final one of these sort of five
pillars of Sam Harris thinking the big
one is you're a neocon so I think we
should define neocon first you want it
you want to handle that or you want me
to well I think it means many things to
many people but it's it's the it's the
the attitude toward foreign policy that
we I think most was was canonized by
people like Richard Perle and Paul
Wolfowitz in the in the run-up to the
first or invasion of Iraq after 9/11
this idea that we can go in in a very
muscular way and just create nations
along Democratic lines and that our
foreign policy should be very aggressive
and and we'll fight them over there so
we don't have to fight them here and I
think we've all I mean I was you know I
was never for the Iraq war I was never
vocally against it either I just was at
every moment through that process I was
just painfully aware that I had no idea
what to think about it apart from it
looked very risky and it looked like a
frank distraction from the war in
Afghanistan which did seem to me to be
necessary and seems like something we
were probably going to botch one thing
you can say against neo conservatism
which is that it is idealistic to a
degree that now seems not at all
sustainable and we should have learned a
lesson at this point which is we don't
do this very well we don't nation build
very well we have a political
environment where we just can't stay
committed to these things even if we
were doing it well you know we we have
we view everything through a four year
you know presidential lens right an
election cycle and so and these are
these are multi decade commitments if
we're going to do this this well so but
Iraq looks like a disaster and it looked
like a disaster for most of the time
apart from you know 15 minutes there
after the surge and I certainly don't
consider myself in neocon I just I just
think we have to be honest about in in
ethical terms
what is really going on in the world
when if you were going to say that we
never should have gone into Iraq which i
think is a reasonable thing to say and
it was a reasonable thing to say then
you just hey it was only decent to admit
how depressing a claim this really is
we're saying that that Iraq is a place
that requires a psychopathic thug to run
it given the level of religious
sectarianism given the fact that when
you remove a butcher like Saddam Hussein
everyone starts killing their neighbor
right which is which is in fact what
happened and which is in fact the
political and religious reality we
underestimated when we walked in there
thinking that they were just going to
put flowers and the barrels of our guns
and welcomed us as liberators so it's a
it's a very depressing thing to admit
about the state of of a place like Iraq
but and I think we should all my view
Iraq as initially we went when Saddam
was there as a kind of hostage crisis
you have a totally illegitimate regime
run by barbarians keeping tens of
millions of people hostage and and so
that the the people who criticize the
war based on saying that it was a
sovereign government and we should never
have gone in there because it's not
that's just a failure to engage with the
moral reality which is this was a
terrible place to live and if we could
have done something to help these people
we should have and there are many
countries that fit that description I
mean North Korea is one of them if there
would be some way to to depose that
regime and liberate the North Koreans we
should do it now we know that it would
just be a bloody mess if we tried and
we're learning that more and more in
these other societies but and so
neoconservatism I don't know what its
current state is now but I can't imagine
anyone is you know even Wolfowitz or
pearl is I can't imagine any of them are
as saying when about the possibility of
building a nation anywhere from scratch
right that's actually a great point like
these guys still believing that idea do
they think if we went back into Iraq
right now would it would it be any
better I somehow doubt it no no I and
it's but the idea that that we created
Isis by going into Iraq that's also just
delusional I mean the the set of ideas
that gives us Isis that is the set of
ideas and the level of sectarianism that
gave us the civil war that that you know
we could barely contain that drove us
out of Iraq and that set of ideas in one
or another degree it's been animating
subsets of the Muslim world for a very
long time right so this is where I think
some of your critics would say well
you're blaming things more on religion
than the geopolitics because had we
never gone to Iraq Saddam would still be
there and at rest
Isis would be controlled but basically
you're saying this this thing sort of
would have bubbled up one way or another
is that well no but I love God no but if
Isis if those religious sectarian
commitments were controlled by a
dictator that's a man with the yeah
that's that seems to me an intrinsically
unstable situation at some point they're
going to they're going to bubble up but
to let's just admit how depressing that
remedy is right and we're talking about
someone who's got you know torture
chamber is running full time and he's
got sons who show up at people's
weddings and rape the bride and I mean
it's just it's like this is just a
playground for sociopaths if that's what
it takes to modulate the the sunni-shia
internecine animosity you know that's it
say okay that does not exonerate
religion right and it does not exonerate
that level of commitment to divisive
theology and so it's um and there you
know I think it's a yeah I I think it is
totally appropriate to be humble about
how hard it is to help people in these
circumstances but if you look at a place
like Rwanda right where we you know
clintons one regret was that we didn't
do more to help or to prevent that
genocide and if you look at a total
failure to intervene and the resulting
massacre of nearly a million people and
you say okay that was that was something
we should not play that hand precisely
that way again right we should do
something differently we should have
intervened well then what do you think
we should do to the you know that what's
happening to these CDs in under the
Islamic state you know we've got people
being crucified by the side of the road
we've got thousands of sex slaves we've
got the gays being thrown from rooftops
we so do we intervene or not you know
it's I think it's it's not obvious that
there's anything we can do in each one
of these circumstances to help people
but the idea that you are a moral
monster to even think that we should
intervene is is deeply suspect